Donald Trump was asked finally about Ron
DeSantis possibly running against him
and more generally about Ron DeSantis
Trump's answer is stunning and insane
and it is like that of a mafia dawn of
sorts Trump appeared on the water cooler
with David Brody of course Trump not
appearing in visual form as he often is
literally phoning these in lately Trump
asked about DeSantis here is his insane
answer I got him elected Spirit simple
he would have never if I if I said I
wasn't going to endorse you foreign
he was very nice in the sense uh the uh
Mueller hugs
they just that is that is a bunch of
spaghetti thrown at the wall but it's it
just none it's four different things but
the most important there is
DeSantis won by 19 and Trump barely
mentioned the guy now Trump says well I
endorsed him but I didn't go crazy with
the endorsement Trump specifically
excluded DeSantis from his final rally
in Florida choosing to campaign only for
Marco Rubio and not Ron DeSantis
DeSantis won by 19 even though the
polling had him only Plus 11.
desantis's win is proof that Trump's
endorsement is worth a lot less than
Trump thinks not a lot more and now
Trump is getting all mixed up because he
knows what is potentially coming in 2024
between him and Ron DeSantis you know he
was one of about a hundred congressmen
who had fought for man so you know I
felt I felt I might as well enjoy so
because I didn't know Adam brought them
but uh he was a three he was ready to
drop out of the race it was all done
Adam Putnam had that that nomination
locked up you know the Republican
nomination
he had it locked up it was done and when
I uh as Adam Putnam said to me when I
met him a year later I didn't know him
at all but I saw him he said it was like
a nuclear bomb went off a nuclear weapon
went off when you endorse him the race
was over he said he didn't even spend
his money there was no way he could have
beaten him after I endorsed him so you
know now I hear he might want to run
against me so we'll handle that the way
I handle things we will handle that the
way I handle things by which Trump means
character assassination
Petty nicknames name calling maybe even
attacking the physical appearance of
desantis's wife as he did to Ted Cruz
that's what Trump means by we'll handle
it the way I handle things and this
could really be Trump's undoing or it
could be desantis's undoing remember we
don't know it's not obvious that
DeSantis can actually handle a national
campaign against Donald Trump this
interview was Bonkers Trump then moved
on to saying that he is fighting the
Deep State Trump is still fully on this
conspiracy stuff saying he's he's got
the Deep State against him folks this is
a former president this is equivalent to
saying it's the Illuminati who tried to
end his candidacy and and you know I'm
beating the Deep state I'm fighting the
Deep State and winning you are and you
can't just be a real I think I am a very
nice person but if you're going to win
we have to be tough and we have to fight
back right and again I was under siege
and I explained that to people soon as I
explain it they always agree yeah
basically you have to fight back and
when you fight back you know I want to
fight to win I want to win for the
country I want to win for the people and
you know I could see it kellyanne saying
well he wasn't very nice but I don't
want to be nice these are people that
are thugs they're very sick and very bad
people and if I fight back I it's you
don't sound as nice as you should but
Trump's the victim guys the Deep state
is against him everyone's against him
he's just fighting for what's his and
everybody calls him mean what a victim
this guy is Trump then weighed in on the
border and as is often the case made
something up whole cloth that is untrue
see if you can spot it here like this
this Porter is a disgrace and I don't
know if you know they're letting in
prisoners but they're letting in all
their people from mental institutions
many countries yeah letting them in from
that they're emptying out their mental
institutions into the United States they
are emptying out their mental
institutions into the United States this
would be on a Jeopardy category called
things that are not happening and this
would be the Daily Double
um that is of course not happening and
it's not enough to say they're emptying
out their prisons into the country which
is what Trump used to say you always
have to become more hyperbolic so now
it's they're emptying out their mental
institutions Trump lastly then of course
talking about January 6th and um says
that he did absolutely nothing wrong
when it comes to January 6. what about
January 6. do you think Merrick Garland
is going to indict you or starting
January 6 and what would be the Fallout
if he decided to do that right well I
can't imagine because I did absolutely
nothing wrong
right all of the other things that have
come out we've done absolutely nothing
wrong uh we uh I protested to this day I
protest that election that election was
a disaster right and so what Trump is
saying of course is that the rioters
were right to be there because Trump
really did win and the protesters
rioters and insurrectionists knew it and
so they were right to be there this is
as dangerous as you can imagine for a
guy who lost incited a riot is on the
verge of being indicted and is now
running again and one other aspect of
this interview that we're going to look
at separately
the evangelicals are not only turning on
Trump trump is turning on the
evangelicals
one of our sponsors today is zipix
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipx has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below